ce que nous sommes ou styron bien sûr
est ce que j'ai voulu faire en
travaillant d'ailleurs avec tout d'abord
avec des architectes avec un décorateur
sur le styrène
ce que j'ai voulu faire c'est d'abord un
point de rencontre c'est à dire un
endroit où se retrouveraient les gens
les gens de goût mais tout le monde ou
si c'est à dire que de faire quelque
chose qui ressemble de plus en plus de
plus près et enfin à ce que j'estime
être le beau et le noble et ce que
j'aime en fait donc j'ai ma vieille
bière j'aime j'aime l'ambiance chaude
d'aider des théâtres et des
et aussi un peu d
des boîtes de nuit et ma vie d'artiste
peut-être kim a prédisposé à aimer les
choses
la nuit et c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu
faire dans le kent en fit théâtre et qui
plus être à la fois un théâtre et une
boîte de nuit et c'est ce que j'ai fait
en faisant cette pièce sur nous sommes
bien évidemment j'étais heureux aussi un
restaurant parce que là la bouffe c'est
quelque chose de très important dans la
vie des hommes enfin moi je veux qu'on
soit comme ça et puis un point de
rencontre un bar un endroit ça va être
aussi d'un village mais ça c'est
peut-être l'avenir
où
en
vous
ici auparavant il y avait avait rien y
avait rien ou à peu près ainsi une
petite montée là ce qui nous a fait
garder l'idée de line pour le petit plan
d'eau mais c'était ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler chez nous des trous à vache
c'est à dire les les dix endroits où les
vaches vont boire l'hiver quand il ya de
l'eau et puis derrière nous il n'y avait
rien du tout c'était un bois comme le
bois en face et mais je crois que c'est
un endroit fantastique c'est l'arrière
pays ce à quatre kilomètres de la mer et
c'est un endroit fantastique où il fait
vraiment très beau est ce que je peux
dire aussi pour avoir découvert sa dent
en creusant un petit peu c'est que c'est
anciennement enfin il ya sans doute de
millénaire le bord de mer ici jusqu'en à
trouver aussi bien des coquillages à un
mètre mètre cinquante de profondeur
on a trouvé des fonds des formats en
fait donc le fond de la rivière de la
trinité sur mer c'est ici il ya bien et
bien des années
donc il n'y avait rien c'est de
l'imagination ces deux là là
architecture contemporaine fait avec de
très vieilles pierres dont certaines
datent du cadet 15e 16e et 17e siècles
et c'est cependant je crois c'est
moderne
sterwen ça veut dire c'est une
contraction de styron guen c'est à dire
sterenn ces étoiles c'est la même racine
que star en anglais et graines sur blanc
dans ses de l'étoile blanche peut-être
la polaire peut-être autre chose
j'ai envie de faire mon mon petit
château des mille et une nuits et puis
comme la chanson rendait cette chose
possible grâce à des rentrées d'argent
quand même assez importante
j'ai là je crois davantage de penser que
l'argent n'est vraiment strictement
qu'un moyen et j'ai voulu le prouver en
utilisant tout ce que j'avais même un
peu juste pour faire quelque chose d'un
peu exceptionnel je pense qu'une vie une
vie mérite d'être vécue dans la mesure
où elle rigole un peu
on fait des choses un peu folles un peu
dingue et je crois qu'on ne fait rien
d'extraordinaire sent un peu de folie
qui le merveilleux à notre époque c'est
que la chanson quand même si elle fait
faire d'un tas de cochonneries permet
quand même quelques fois des à des
auteurs et des compositeurs donc à des
poètes un talent certain qui crevaient
de faim aujourd'hui certains peuvent
gagner de l'argent et même peut-être
quelquefois en gagner beaucoup
alors je crois que c'est un peu ce qui
m'est arrivé cet argent gelé réinvesti
je pense dans dans l'art ce qui me
paraissait normal parce que les
critiques qu'on a fait sur le site et
roanne ça n'a pas beaucoup plus
importantes comme beaucoup d'importance
ça fait mal au début bien sûr mais ça
n'a pas beaucoup d'importance quand on
songe en fait que aujourd'hui on fait
tellement de bêtises avec du fric
pourquoi pas faire acheter je crois que
c'est une bonne façon que j'utilise
j'ai toujours été très fier d'être
breton est très fier de ma bretagne
je suis moins cher des bretons du budget
construit aussi roanne parce que je
pense que la manière de réagir d'un
certain nombre d'entre eux
et très très décevante et devant le
ch'ti juan leur manière de réagir est
tellement été aberrante enfin à mon sens
je ne je ne détiens pas la vérité je
revendique un une parce que le ch'ti
roanne c'est une vérité c'est une
réalité mais la manière de réagir d'un
certain nombre de bretons m'a beaucoup
attristé quoi et je crois que cette
façon de voir les choses ne me dit rien
de bon en ce qui concerne l'avenir donc
heureusement ce n'est pas à la tête a
été les bretons et je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de bretons qui ne pense pas
comme ça le rangement
ça fait 15 ans 15 ans 16 ans que je fais
ce métier j'ai commencé à écrire des
chansons en 1961 et pour je sais pas
exactement le nombre de chansons que
j'ai écrites mais je lui imagine comme
ça je me dis plupart disent alors sur la
sphère entre 150 et 170 lancement
ah c'est très loin magie déjà elle était
si jolie et guinguettes c'est encore
merveilleusement présent parce que c'est
ce qui me donne un petit peu confiance
et ce qui me fait plaisir c'est que
finalement ces chansons qui n'ont pas
beaucoup vieilli les enregistrements un
peu mais pas pas tellement les chansons
et mais malgré tout dans ma liste c'est
loin parce que c'est déjà il ya 15 ans
peut-être 14 ans mais c'est une autre
chose j'ai l'impression qui s'est passé
tellement de choses depuis que
c'est déjà très loin toutes ces chansons
la première fois que j'ai entendu
siffler je crois était si jolie j'ai
fait je me rappelle j'étais c'était
c'était chez moi j'habite un immeuble à
l'époque dans le xviiie arrondissement à
paris
je suis descendu et j'ai chaud autour de
la table pour savoir qui s'y plaît l
indécision et j'ai fini par découvrir
que ça venait d'une fenêtre je dois
avouer que ça fait certain plaisir en
plastique ça c'est peut-être plus
étonnant encore que que de s'entendre à
la radio j'entends à la radio c'est la
première fois où les premières fois
c'est quelque chose d'assez peu
d'enfants restent la comcom fives et
c'était un plaisir extraordinaire mais
sans temps de siffler entendre siffler
une de ses chansons dans la rue ça fait
toujours plaisir formidable
tout ferment les yeux ou tu dis serait
merveilleux
ça je ne suis pas un chanteur breton je
suis breton de coeur et d'âme je suis
devenu breton de naissance et comme je
vais chanter une chanson qui s'appelle
un peu de sang breton l'heure mais je ne
suis pas un chanteur breton tout
simplement parce que j'ai été élevé loin
de la culture celtique
parce que je ne veux je ne parle pas le
breton je venais quelques petits mots
évidemment je suis un minimum de mots en
breton
mais ça ne va pas plus loin je suis un
chanteur français
je chante la france aime à demain ma
seule langue est le français et
et comment dirais-je donc j'ai toujours
chanté en français espère simplement
comme un champion français et c'est un
bien quand même temps un certain nombre
de pays que des chanteurs français
cela dit j'adore des équipes comme style
elle qui fait un travail fantastique
seront sur la musique celte et sur les
douze oeuvres alors typiquement bretonne
en fin de combat donne aujourd'hui ça je
leur tire mon chapeau mais moi ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas mon royaume si je peux
dire donc je suis breton mais je ne suis
pas un chanteur breton
sur m6
nous sommes pourquoi il faut
nous
je pense que presque tous les gens
presque tous les hommes toutes les
femmes tous les humains un vers l'âge de
35 ans 30 entre 30 et 40 ans tout au
moins on tâche changement radical
d'attitude et ont un besoin vital de
retrouver leurs racines c'est un retour
aux sources c'est le retour vers les
racines et moi ça n'est pas spécial à
moi c'est mon voeu le buzz que l'adie en
ce qui concerne la bretagne et la
merveilleuse monte écrit moi je les
crèmes manière c'est-à-dire en
construisant ça je les traduis de la
manière qui nous semblait la plus haute
et la plus intéressante et la plus
possible et ce qui est important c'est
quand même de laisser sur terre je suis
pas un caillou comme le styrène un gros
caillou c'est effectivement important
mais je ne sais pas si c'est plus
important de laisser un cailloux du
petit air de musique je conseille
on
et
oh
e